perhaps the stories of this group of
Asylum Seekers sums up Britain's broken
immigration system
we've met them in a park to hear their
concerns about the accommodation they're
in but housing Asylum Seekers whilst
they wait for their claims to be
processed is costing the taxpayer 5.6
million pounds a day in a cost of living
crisis nobody is happy
this family say they fled Iran in fear
of the authorities but didn't imagine
life for their children would be like
this they need fresh food fresh
vegetable we don't have any facilities
in my room any fridge microwave is not
good
is not suitable for families
these three Asylum Seekers are from
Central America one says she's fled to
avoid powerful drug scangs they're also
unhappy with the food where they're
staying
sharing videos of the meals they say
they've been given which they describe
as moldy rotten or not cooked properly
we spoke to the Caterers who say
complaints like this will be taken
seriously in me in my case I spent a lot
of days without breakfast without lunch
or dinner
uh because I was looking down and I saw
this kind of food and I prefer to eat
because every time that I eat that I
have diarrhea I have a stomach ache what
would you say to other people who are
thinking of claiming asylum in the UK
and that process is hard and the process
is long the Asylum Seekers are amongst
several hundred GP Joe Nash has access
to she says around one in ten have seen
a doctor about stomach problems which
could be linked to what they're eating
she's also concerned some children of
Asylum Seekers are not putting on weight
of the children that we've weighed
two-thirds of them since arrival have
either stayed the same or have actually
lost weight that's really unusual and
really alarming in children this is over
like a six seven month period
the home office says food provided in
Asylum hotels meets all NHS standards
and concerns will be addressed
but with the government facing criticism
over the conditions that manston
processing center in Kent a home office
Minister ignited debate after saying it
was a cheek for people who'd entered the
country illegally to complain about
conditions you think they're ungrateful
in response Downing Street said migrants
deserve to be treated with compassion
and respect but as Asylum Seekers
continue to be bossed from manston to
ease overcrowding this was a week which
reminded us yet again of just how
divisive an issue migration is Lisa
Holland Sky News